we want to hear from you what you think
of Drake tying the glee class Bleak
House record for the most entries on the
Billboard Hot 100 yeah Wow jeez that's a
lot future song life is good the Drake
is featured on debuted at number two
this week on the chart making it Drake's
207 entry on the chart tying Glee for
the most entries ever hears very quick
reaction on insta last night one more to
go hmm that's all I have to say thank ya
207 that's crazy so that's the thing I
mean we features feature shouldn't count
yeah cuz I was thinking happened with
Nicki Minaj Riley
everyone was up in ours and she passed
Aretha Franklin yeah and then eventually
something I think was like in their 70s
doesn't like that she got but yeah I
think it's getting a little ridiculous
at this point like now yeah we're just
realizing some of these Billboard chart
records that are broken it doesn't make
sense like say like Old Town Road
breaking the next-best bag number one
like that's like a streak that yeah like
that still makes sense but these ones
it's just a totally different world in
terms of releasing music that really
what happens like when they release an
album every single song initially tracks
for one week cuz that one yeah you're
down with that well but really they
count this individual songs yeah so I
find it's getting a little ridiculous I
also don't think that Glee should really
hold a record it was all covers I know
and then like it was it was it was a
promotional tool for a television show
and they're just one week [ __ ] it would
last for one week exactly so I don't
even think that like I'm sure yes Glee
but what is Glee Glee was a television
show right like please not a band
Glee's not I don't think they're always
credited as just Glee cast that's how
they did it yeah even if it's just a
soulless I think they should count
whoever's behind Glee should be the
actual person who artist I guess would
have been Drake right I was weirdly
gonna say - they're like oh well I mean
obviously Drake is gonna have one more
history so he's gonna break this record
yeah but would like say I'm sure they
will eventually do a Glee revival or
reboot like would they be able to extend
and they credit it the right way if they
just call it Gleek Leake Xavier Balu
this high street I hope I don't have to
have that commerce that's think it's
Drake and Glee competing for the most
entries in the hardware
we haven't I